that women wants to be murdered really
ah i think you got something there
my lady loves all that murder um like
fake
you know hold you down and put a ski
mask on and yeah all that [ __ ]
brian laundry all that stuff with that
man they're looking for that everybody
all these chicks want to bang that guy
yeah it's a weird fetish these ladies
that it's also all murder all the time
they love murder do you think that and
also we're not gonna have any good
murderers anymore that's done
that's i mean there's just too much
digital
footprint yeah
i just can't believe laundry's still on
the lam even with dog the the n-word
bounty hunter
and he's still out there he might be
dead in a ravine for all i know i don't
know i think if you've gone that long
i feel like you keep riding it out cause
you've already
you've already killed yeah you've
already been hiding for a month or two
like i think at that point
if you haven't turned yourself in or
taking your life after a couple weeks i
feel like you've got you've gotten into
that you're in vanderslut kind of vibe
where you're like
what can i do what else yes can i god
how long can i hide what
and it's almost seems
exciting
uh yeah it's definitely life and death
it's dark but if you imagine wake up in
the morning and you are somebody that is
untraceable yeah
you nobody can locate you
here's what it seems it seems relaxing
you think so i would be on edge
constantly i feel like at least you're
like you're you're not on your phone
you're at least spending time like out
in nature probably i feel like you're
doing the things that a lot of us need
to do if he didn't do the murder i would
say
he could be like a homeopath or
something right right he could open up a
thing in maui
yeah like a cbd shop or some [ __ ]
yeah he's probably sitting at a bar
somewhere in oklahoma with a mustache
and shades on drinking a beer and going
oh [ __ ] i'm on the news yeah you know
and he's i bet he's milking it like how
about this [ __ ] psycho huh the guy
next time's like i know right yeah i
hope they catch that guy's like yeah
[ __ ] him
probably enjoying it
and halloween he gets to come party too
right he can dress up
every day is halloween for him yeah
but to be able to one night come down
from the hills and freaking let it loose
do jager bombs with a freaking mime
right
right you know just come down and just
party dude
piss on a mummy just have fun man
halloween was fun
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this one
you